l'invité politique tous les matins à 8h
15 en direct sur public sénat
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo accompagner michael
the must pour ical
alors nous voici ensemble pour passer au
crible une semaine d'actualité à
politique et parlementaire bovine et par
quoi dominer deviner par quoi pardo par
la guerre interne à l'ump un nouveau mot
a surgi cette semaine le rhume pour
rassemblement ump le nouveau groupe
parlementaire créée avec 71 députés
derrière françois fillon la ligne rouge
est franchie dit jean françois copé
la perspective d'un référendum auprès
des militants s'éloigne mais les
discussions continuent en coulisses et
pendant ce temps les sénateurs ump
décident de rester unie pas de scission
du groupe parlementaire mais les
fillonistes majoritaire ont quand même
créé cette association rhume et il
réclame l'organisation d'une nouvelle
élection
enfin pendant la crise de travail
parlementaire continue au sénat les
communistes ont cédé au rejet du projet
de loi de finances de l'île 13 puis le
lendemain du projet de budget de la
sécurité sociale à leur palmarès quatre
texte retoqué est avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité à
remords à bonjour bonjour vous êtes
président du nouveau centre député de
l'eure vous avez rejoint l'aventuré des
é co fondateur de lidé homo fondateur de
lidé linde union des démocrates et
indépendants qui présidé par jean louis
borloo mais vous vous présidez le
conseil national on va bien sûr y
revenir
dans cette émission est avec nous pascal
perrineau bonjour je vous êtes directeur
du cevipof c'est le centre de recherches
politiques de sciences po paris avec
vous aurez essayé bien évidemment de
comprendre ce qui se cache derrière
cette guerre à l'ump n'ont jamais rien
pascal perrineau d'innovation
et on commence avec la crise à l'ump
semaines numéro deux et si vous avez
raté le principal épisodes de la semaine
c'était mardi la commission des recours
ayant proclamé jean françois copé
président de l'ump françois fillon
organisent la riposte
il annonce la création de son groupe à
l'assemblée
surgit alors un troisième personnage
nicolas sarkozy explications et résumé
de la journée avec ahmed tazir plus du
range et de caméras l'attendent
françois fillon essaie tant bien que mal
de se frayer un chemin dans un instant
il va prononcer la contre attaque après
la proclamation officielle de jean
françois copé comme patron de l'ump
un hold-up selon françois fillon comme
un signe la larme de sécurité retenti
quelques minutes avant son arrivée sur
l'estrade
puis françois fillon prend la parole je
demande à jean françois copé
une nouvelle élection par les adhérents
dans les trois mois
dans la tente de cette nouvelle élection
j'ai décidé avec les députés qui me
suivent de constituer un groupe
parlementaire qui aura pour nom le
rassemblement ump
le discours terminé inutile d'en
rajouter plus je me suis exprimé merci
quelques minutes plus tard le discours
fait son effet les coups de téléphone
fusent nicolas sarkozy appelle françois
fillon puis nicolas sarkozy appelle jean
françois copé l'ancien chef de l'état
veut à tout prix que les deux
protagonistes se rencontrent enfin
ce sera chose faite dans le bureau du
député maire de meaux à l'assemblée
nationale à la sortie
jean françois copé raconte le deal avec
françois fillon et j'ai à cette occasion
demandé à françois fillon de renoncer à
son projet de constituer un groupe
dissident de l'ump ait renoncé aussi à
ce son projet de recours en justice
en contrepartie j'ai proposé à françois
fillon que l'on donne la parole aux
militantes et aux militants de l'ump
pour qu'ils se prononcent par référendum
pour savoir s'ils souhaitent ou non que
l'on recommence à voter réponse du
berger à la bergère
françois fillon est favorable à un
référendum sur un nouveau vote des
militants ump il fait parler sa garde
rapprochée
il ya une évolution très nette alors que
ce matin n'était pas question de voter à
nouveau on voit qu'il ya un progrès qui
est fait nous l'acceptons comme étant
positif pour préserver l'unité du
mouvement vive le référendum
en attendant la famille ump fait chambre
à part
mais sans divorce pour le moment voilà
le mardi se terminer par une note
d'espoir et le mercredi patatras
françois et jean françois copé furieux
de voir françois fillon ne pas
abandonner l'idée de son groupe
parlementaire est bien fait marche
arrière fin de négociation le référendum
s'éloigne écouter la réponse arrive ce
matin je l' ai appris hier soir tard
publié au journal officiel le groupe
dissident ruban rouge pour comme on dit
avec 60 et quelques députés celui ci
pourra partir de là je considère que les
conditions ce nom ne se ne sont pas
réunies voilà il n'y aura braderait
faire écouter partir du moment où il ya
un groupe parlementaire publié au
journal officiel dissidents c'est à dire
exactement l'averse de ce qu'on a
de ce qu'on a évoqué bon ben voila je
crois que chacun maintenant comprend ce
qu'il faut comprendre
voilà comment est ce que vous vous
comprenez tout ce qui se passe ou est ce
que vous dites ces deux hommes sont
tombés sur la tête pense qu'il faut que
ça s'arrête mais je pense que derrière
ça il ya en fait la construction alors
ces deux rpr deux anciens rpr qui se
combattent
mais derrière ça y est une fiction qui
est la création de l'ump l'ump s'est
constitué en 2002 dans un contexte très
particulier où jacques chirac n'a pas
besoin des centristes pour gagner
une collection présentiel et constitue
un vaste rassemblement qui tient pendant
10 ans pour une raison simple c'est que
le chef de l'ump à l'élysée et donc
l'obligation de solidarité de
collégialité de solidité fait que le
système tient
et puis dès que l'ump tombe dans
l'opposition eh bien ça s'effondre parce
que en réalité la droite et le centre et
l'ensemble de cette grande famille
politique à a trop de divergences
notamment est d'autant plus que vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
droitisation considérable beaucoup de
tabous qui sont tombés en clair pendant
40 ans ou 50 ans il y avait des mots il
y avait un positionnement politique qui
étaient interdits parce qu'on avait le
souvenir de vichy et aujourd'hui on est
à peu près on a le droit de reprendre
les mêmes thématiques qu'on pouvait les
prendre sous la troisième république
avec les croix de feu et maurras donc
tout ça amène à déporter l'ump à droite
tellement qu'un jour ou l'autre le
système finit par s'effondrer
donc je pense que ces fonds qui est un
fin observateur la vie politique
d'accord avec cette analyse pas sûr donc
c'est l'échec de l'ump du projet de
l'ump de constituer un grand parti dans
l'espace des droite et du centre
pourquoi parce que au delà de ce que dit
hervé morin
il ya aussi l'histoire de tous ces
courants politiques comme le disait rené
rémond il y a des droites en france avec
des traditions extrêmement différentes
on a tenté de les fondre dans un même
creuset ça ne marche pas alors pour en
revenir à cette semaine à cette crise
spécifiquement l'issue c'est quoi pour
vous quand comment on va se sortir de là
là on en est aux tractations alors
l'issue il ya tout n'est pas encore
complètement bloquée bon les statuts on
l'a bien vu leur corps au statut ça ne
suffit pas la coco la commission de
course insuffisant alors on s'est tourné
vers l'extérieur
le père fondateur alain juppé ça ne
marche pas l'autorité tutélaire du
président de la république ça
apparemment ça ne marche pas même si
nicolas sarkozy reste toujours très
actif mais sont tous même que cette idée
à moins que les deux hommes est intérêt
à une véritable scission il ya des
jeunes scission
assemblée nationale il y aura-t-il une
scission dans le parti on voit pas très
bien deux groupes parlementaires vivre
leur vie sans que le parti à un moment
ou un autre
n'éclate donc si on rentre dans cette
perspective au fond ça veut dire qu'il
n'y aura pas de sortie de crise
on va s'installer dans deux partis issus
de l'ump en tout cas de groupes
parlementaires c'est l'élection
seulement je ne vois pas c'est la
réélection avec une commission
indépendante afin de donner de donner à
cette élection une autre allure que la
piteuse allure qu'elle a pu la
commission indépendante qui ne serait
pas du tout des personnalités
indépendantes dans lesquelles il est à
la fois des représentants de l'ump et
bien sûr des gens qui n'ont rien à voir
avec une mpm quand on entend un
référendum pour savoir s'il faut voter
ça rime à rien nous fait on commence à
envoyer sa voix en même temps une
nouvelle élection vous imaginez le
bordel des mois un retour à la campagne
et parena région
maintenant c'est pour un parti politique
c'est une épreuve une élection alors si
en plus de ça vous remettez ça c'est pas
quelque chose je dis simplement pascal
perrineau alors luder n'a jamais été un
parti centralisée unique et unitaire
comme un peu comme a pu l'être l'udf
comme a pu l'être l'ump mais mais je
rappelle qu'on a eu deux groupes ne se
donnait en 88 où il y avait grosso modo
le cds qui avait fait son groupe et le
reste de l'udf qui avait constitué son
propre que la fission et donc oui en
fait le début de la session pour moi
c'est le jour où il ya où il a manqué un
leadership c'est à dire en 95 quand
léotard bayrou giscard et monory se
neutralisent et vont chercher balladur
ce jour là c'est le début de la mort de
lui donner donc l'ariane qui est sûre
leadership qui se pose est donc je crois
pour françois fillon et jean françois
copé le disait avant le début de
l'émission leur intérêt réciproque si
l'un et l'autre ont en tête l'élection
présidentielle c'est de ne pas faire
d'élection c'est à dire d'avoir deux
groupes parlementaires et de se dire un
lieu le rendez vous il est pour 2016 au
moment des primaires s'il ya des
primaires mais est-ce qu'ils ont les
moyens d'attendre notamment
financièrement est ce qu'il peut mais ce
qu'ils peuvent le faire
oui oui non non ils peuvent avoir les
de l'assemblée c'est quand même une arme
de dissuasion pour françois fillon
notamment on sait que si les
parlementaires fillonniste décide de ne
pas verser l'argent à l'ump c'est 6
millions d'euros quand même c'est arrivé
quelques milles parlementaire ça permet
de voir venir
oui ça permet de faire vivre une
organisation cependant il faut bien voir
que s'il y a des primaires ces primaires
elles concerneront un autre corps
électoral qu'en français concernant les
français dits de droite ce projet du
maire de droite ou du centre est assez
avait fait totalement verte totalement
ouverte
totalement ouverte puisqu'il y avait
même un candidat qui était d'un candidat
radical qui ne venaient pas des
capacités de la droite le fasse est-ce
qu'il faut qu'ils ouvrent ces primaires
à tous les français il faudra voir le
climat dans les années 2015 2016
d'accord grenon gens sérieux pour nous
la question se posera aussi est-ce que
nous participons primaire puisque nous
sommes clairement dans une coalition
gouvernementale affiché à l'avance
contrairement à françois bayrou donc est
ce que nous y participons est ce que nos
participants des primaires du centre où
ce que nous considérons nous devons
avoir notre propre candidat dans un
processus de sélection interne parce
qu'a priori juste un petit mot vous
parliez de nicolas sarkozy tout à
l'heure est ce que ça vous a surpris que
sa médiation échoue à ce point il n'a
plus l'autorité morale nécessaire pour
sarkozy d'ailleurs cette présentation
qui serait fou revenir là dessus nicolas
sarkozy a perdu les élections et l'ump a
perdu gravement les élections
législatives
je regardais sous la vème république
jamais la droite classique 1
c'est-à-dire tous ceux qui sont quelque
part entre la droite extrême et le
centre d'hyper centre indépendant
inquiète jamais la droite classique
n'avait fait un aussi mauvais score un
premier tour de législatives et pourtant
cela venait naturellement vers nicolas
sarkozy ayant en coin donc c'est l'échec
c'est l'échec du de la période
sarkozyste et c'est l'échec de l'ump et
là moi je crois pour prendre un peu de
hauteur la crise de l'ump s'explique
comme ça ils ont tout fait à l'envers
ils ont cherché d'abord à sélectionner
le président mais il fallait d'abord
porté le juste diagnostic sur la
séquence électorale présidentielle
législatives se poser quelques
réflexions et quelques questions
en termes de que faire maintenant est ce
qu'on s'inscrit dans ce concert
mémorable est tout à l'heure en effet la
droitisation est ce qu'il y a une vraie
droitisation d'ailleurs la société
française selon que vous preniez non
mais c'est très différent d'un d'un
niveau à l'autre
vous pouvez avoir une droitisation parme
sur le terrain pendant que de la demande
d'autorités de verticalité en termes de
libéralisme des moeurs n'est pas vrai il
n'ya pas de droitisation parce qu'ils
sont communs à des populations
connaissent team électoralement
divergentes les classes populaires ont
considéré à gauche même si tout ça est
d'être largement cours affiché
aujourd'hui et disons les bourgeois créé
c'est à droite le mode frontière même si
ça ne raisonne pas de la même façon pour
l'un et l'autre c'est un mot qu'on
entend des deux côtés le mot de
d'anticapitalisme ou d'anti libéralisme
on l'entend des deux côtés le mot de
peur de l'étranger on entend des deux
côtés et donc il ya très clairement des
propos qu'on entend dans la société
française qui sont des propos qu'on
n'entendait pas ya 20 ans et qui sont
partagés j'allais dire par toutes les
couches sociales de la société française
quand même franchement alors moi mais on
va revenir sur cette histoire de guerre
à l'ump vous savez que françois fillon
lui il a réuni ses troupes au sénat et
au sein du groupe il est majoritaire au
sénat il appelle un nouveau vote
mais le pas de groupes dissidents comme
explique jérôme rabier après la création
hier d'un groupe à part à l'assemblée
françois fillon a consacré sa seule
sortie publique de la journée aux
sénateurs qui le soutiennent autour d'un
petit déjeuner il est venu avec eux
concocté la stratégie à adopter pour le
groupe sénatorial de l'ue m
et à la sortie la demande etc etc les
nous voulons regretté je crois que bon
si la sphère du référendum et ne peut
plus tenir parce que jean françois copé
n'en veut pas après l'avoir proposé
nous demandons simplement de que l'on
redonne la parole aux militants c'est la
seule manière d'en sortir et je crois
que c'est d'ailleurs ce que
majoritairement les militants veulent
ils ont alors imposé le vote d'une
motion au groupe dans son ensemble
pourtant dirigé par un proche de jean
françois copé
le sénateur maire de marseille jean
claude gaudin ce dernier a dû se rallier
à la loi du nombre
c'est un débat comme ça s'appelle un
voeu un souhait mais il est clair que
les sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
ump qui sont aussi les responsables
politiques souhaitent que l'on puisse
faire un nouveau vote à l'intérieur de
notre formation politique
d'autres soutiens de jean françois copé
qui n'ont pas pris part au vote pour
marquer leur opposition préfère
minimiser l'ampleur de cette décision je
suis pas sûr que ce texte deux motions
du sénat rajoute grand chose au débat
mais bon il mange pas de pain et si je
puis dire dans la mesure où c'est à la
fois pas une injonction comptes n'a pas
éclaté
fidèle à son image de pondération le
sénat a encore une fois voulu se
différencier
hors de question de diviser une famille
politique déjà affaiblies même si cette
demande de nouveau vote a permis de
vérifier la forte domination des
fillonistes au sein du groupe ump à la
haute-assemblée
pascal perrineau d'un mot quelle
importance accordez au fait que les les
parlementaires les sénateurs ump n'est
pas décidée la scission par rapport à
l'assemblée nationale c'est important
parce que ça montre que dans cet autre
assemblée la logique de l'affrontement
de la scission de la crispation autour
bien de fillon d'un côté de coop et de
l'autre rencontre des réticences et il
faut pas oublier que ces sénateurs sont
aussi l'expression des élus locaux de
l'ump et ses élus locaux de l'ump ils
voient bien que très bientôt dans les
élections locales régionales il y aura
un combat commun et que ça n'est
peut-être pas la solution la plus
intelligente d'aborder sa dans la
dispersion
qui s'annonce en particulier nationale
on va voir comment se passent les
partiels c'est intéressant parce que des
vigies cela que psa allait être balayé
vous allez tous les perdre
et là c'est plus que ça va donner c'est
n'est plus l'expression de la base cette
fois ci et cette session tout cas de la
base parce que regarder également par
exemple dans le quotidien le figaro ce
matin
l'enquète qui est sortie auprès des
électeurs de la droite les électeurs de
l'ump voilà ils veulent une solution qui
était une solution de rassemblement ils
veulent une solution dans le cas sur le
référendum s'imposerait en revenir à
votre parti avec moi pendant que l'ump
se déchire notre rassemblement centriste
de l'udps et y donne l'image de l'unité
de l'unité inauguration mercredi matin
des nouveaux locaux du parti dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris en présence des
principaux responsables politiques du
mouvement dont vous vous étiez présent
pour le discours du président de lyon
jean louis borloo qui profite de cette
crise de l'ump pour réaffirmer sa place
on écoute
force est de constater ce matin que s'il
n'y avait pas lui dit il y aurait
prenons pas de force sereine crédible de
l'alternance en france nous ne nous
réjouissons pas de ce qui se passe chez
nos partenaires de la coalition car dans
les démocraties il faut des coalitions
on voit quand même un petit sourire un
combien de demandes d'adhésion en plus à
lui dédié puis au nouveau centre
oui c'est vrai qu'on connaît une
embellie mais qui est à mon sens n'a
rien à voir sauf marginalement avec les
déchirements de l'ump quand vous êtes
méditant vous déchirez pas votre carte
par exemple partie d'un côté ça c'est
des conneries
ceux qui disent ah il dit ouais mais
c'est marginal le mouvement d'adhésion
que nous connaissons est un moment
d'adhésion qui correspond tout
simplement au fait qu'il ya une
dynamique et que ceux qui sont
centristes libéraux européens humanistes
se disent enfin ils ont cessé
leur machine à baffes qui faisait que à
chaque élection à chaque moment il est
finalement n'était plus du tout audible
donc ont découragé tout le monde dont
reviennent vers nous moi je le vois
d'ailleurs quand on a des réunions des
têtes des visages qu'on a connus du
temps de l'udf rayonnante et qui se
disent peut-être qu'elle l'histoire de
cette maison du bailli fait le grand
gagnant deçà de dire à l'ump
ah c'est un des grands gagnants dont on
parle le moins on parle peu parce qu'il
ya une lecture qui à mon avis doit être
prudente qui consiste à dire ce sont les
extrêmes qui en profite
attention quand vous regardez
attentivement les enquêtes d'opinion
aujourd'hui vous apercevez parents que
l'image du front national reste et âme
mais qu'en revanche l'image de lui dit
ce tout nouveau parti politique est en
véritable explosion ou vous regardez
toutes les dernières enquêtes lui dei a
pris plus de 10 points en moins de deux
semaines surtout c'est facile et surtout
on s'est installés c'est à dire que au
moins deux
deux mois les français savent ce que
c'est quand même assez rare c'est dur
d'installer une marque dans une nouvel
électorat une nouvelle vision un espace
sur lequel vous pouvez jouer qui a
manqué pour i derrière vale exige avons
une constellation quoi nous avons des
astres qui nous sont favorables pour le
lancement de notre notre parti après
pour nous il ya deux ans je le premier
c'est celui de préserver cette unité qui
bien entendu sera fragile parce que
celle un centriste est compliquée et
deuxièmement être capable de porter un
discours politique fort audible la
société française n'est pas une société
de consensus c'est requis à cette espèce
de schizophrénie consiste à vouloir le
rassemblement cesser d'opposer les uns
aux autres ce qu'on reprochait nicolas
sarkozy ce que je lui reprochais et en
même temps on n'a jamais eu des français
aussi radicaux il donc il va falloir
qu'on soit capable de porter un discours
de rupture et certainement pas de l'eau
tiède
pascal perrineau si ça marche aussi bien
pour lui d y ont dit merci à jean louis
borloo on dit merci à qui
merci à ceux qui ont su aussi malgré les
divisions très naturelle dans cette
famille qui est issu largement de l'udf
d'avoir su surmonter leur égo leurs
divisions
c'était le projet ensuite sont fragiles
mais bien sûr c'est fragile ensuite
reste à remercier l'ump bien sûr il
reste à remercier également le modem et
le modem et les socialistes parce que
l'usl udi un espace si vous permettez
très rapidement lui dit un espace
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui elle a su
s'unir
aujourd'hui l'ump lui fait un cadeau lui
fait un cadeau de nombreux électeurs de
droite sont en déshérence aujourd'hui
ils sont plus qu'à 4 agacé ils ont
besoin d'un pôle pour
derrière lequel ils vont pouvoir se
rassembler lors des élections mais faut
aussi voir que c'est le fruit de l'échec
d'une stratégie d'un centre qui dit
voilà nous sommes en hypercentre nous
ignorons superbement la bipolarisation
de la vème république
nous ne rentrerons dans aucun système
d'alliances sinon c'est l'échec du modem
oui en vérité c'est pas des militants ou
ça fait ça permet d'avoir des français
qui jusqu'àlors était captif de l'est
d'être à nouveau ouvert un discours
politique issu d'une autre famille
politique c'est ça surtout le le fruit
de l'est de la division et de la guerre
au sein de l'ump si ici à deux ump
ce que françois fillon créé son propre
parti est ce que ça ne risque pas de
nuire aux centristes parce qu'il a une
image de droite sociale qui va aller
peut-être mangé sur cet électorat là
vous savez quand vous regardez tout de
même les enquêtes vous apercevez qu'une
majorité d'électeurs de l'ump de gens
qui sont des sympathisants de l'ump donc
proche de l'appareil rendent
responsables ils disent voilà
aujourd'hui les deux sont responsables
donc ça libère tout même un bel espace
pour bien ce qu'ils sont des alliés et
rivaux dans l'espace des droite et du
centre à savoir lui des dames aux
messieurs si on revient sur cette guerre
à l'ump copé fillon c'est fini pour 2017
ils ont plus aucun espoir parce qu'elle
verrait noir de morrison à nos
politiques ne verrez pas d'accord
absolument pas allez donc lors ce
chapitre pas mort on est jamais chanté
mitterrand est quand même été un chirac
ont été deux exemples incroyable quoi
aller pour clore ce chapitre on vous
propose d'écouter le coup de gueule de
la semaine il vient du député ump
benoist apparu au départ fillonniste et
puis qui a fini par jouer les casques
bleus pendant dix jours mercredi
il résume un peu on pense l'opinion
générale on les écoute il ya un moment
ras-le-bol
il ya un moment tout le monde en a marre
vous en avez marre les militants en ont
marre les français en ont marre
les parlementaires en ont marre des
hommes de bonne volonté ont les mains on
en marre stop
la question c'est plus qu'au pc + fillon
on s'en moque
alors les querelles d'ego c'est bien la
testeuse testostérone pardon c'est
merveilleux mais maintenant stop c'est
plus leur problème c'est plus leurs
enjeux qu'ils se détruisent l'un et
l'autre c'est leur choix c'est leur
droit mais qu'ils n'entraînent pas tout
le monde avec eux c'est tout ce que nous
leur demandons aujourd'hui
bon vous êtes d'accord monsieur ça
suffit la guerre pour l'arrêter magog
oui ça suffit mais les bonnes volontés
en matière politique cela ne suffit pas
si beaucoup pascal perrineau d'être venu
aujourd'hui pour nous accompagner sur ce
nous allons commencer
continuez à commenter la semaine il y à
d'autres actualités que l'ump et mardi
notamment un ancien premier ministre est
auditionné à l'assemblée nationale en ce
mardi lionel jospin est entendu par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée pour
défendre son rapport sur la rénovation
et la déontologie de la vie publique il
est tout principalement attendus sur le
cumul des mandats chloé baïse lionel
jospin présente à la commission des lois
son rapport de la commission de
déontologie et de la vie politique
commandé par le président de la
république en juillet dernier il propose
des réformes qui concernent directement
les parlementaires parmi ces
propositions le parrainage citoyen des
candidats à la présidentielle
la réforme du statut pénal du chef de
l'état mais surtout l'élection de 10%
des députés à la proportionnelle et le
non cumul des mandats
notre proposition est pour les députés
et les sénateurs de limiter les
éventuels cumuls a un mandat simple
celui de conseiller municipal de
conseiller général ou de conseiller
régional
c'est surtout cette dernière réforme qui
a fait réagir les députés ça permettra
un renouvellement et rajeunissement une
féminisation et puis ça permettra
surtout de vraiment exercer pleinement
le monde d'un passionnant qu'est le
mandat de parlementaire il ya plein de
questions que je me pose qui sont dues à
des questions que l'on pose en tant que
mère que j'ai en tant que maire je crois
que c'est important de pouvoir garder
cette règle la de cumul pour les petites
collectivités en tout cas si le non
cumul des mandats est adopté il pourrait
être mis en application dès 2014 aux
élections municipales alors avec moi
vous êtes non seulement députés mais
aussi maire d'une petite commune et
peignent 1500 habitants ce que vous êtes
prêts à laisser ce mandat de maire ça
serait un vrai déchirement
en plus mon village natal mon homme
c'est à ces six là où je me sens
vraiment bien belle et c'est aussi votre
mandat de député wu ching se posera en
son temps non non moi j'ai été très
longtemps favorable à la fin du cumul
des mandats et je dois reconnaître que
j'ai évolué que j'ai changé d'avis j'ai
changé d'avis pour une raison très
simple c'est que je pense que là car dès
qu'on peut faire un toilettage
considérer qu'on se limite à deux
mandats en y intégrant les comités
communaux de souk ahras non sa chute
tout à fait d'accord il faut
probablement encore restreindre le champ
je suis contre cette la fin du cumul
pour une raison simple c'est qu'on est
dans un état centralisé on est dans un
état jacobin et l'élu local qui ne peut
pas s'appuyer être relayés par des élus
nationaux qui eux mêmes sont des élus
locaux
c'est grosso modo des élus locaux à ce
qu'on attende beaucoup d'élus dit j'en
entends aussi d'envoyer senator
sénateurs socialistes aussi on aurait pu
dû d'une part on peut faire une
exception pour le sénat qui
représentants des collectivités locales
mais je parle pour les députés une
administration ne décroche pas son
téléphone quand vous êtes un élu local
quand vous voulez défendre un bout
d'autoroute un échangeur quand vous
voulez défendre je ne sais quelle
infrastructure si vous êtes un élu local
l'administration centrale ne vous entend
pas il y a donc besoin dans cet état
centralisé que des élus locaux ayant des
mandats nationaux puissent porter cette
idée là dans les autres pays allemagne
espagne et italie se sont d'ailleurs
sont pas tous sur la règle du non cumul
mais vous êtes sur des états fédéraux
ayons des régions avec une autonomie
considéra donc si on va vers le non
cumul
il faut aussi en tirer des conséquences
sur l'organisation de nos collectivités
locales et pour ma part beaucoup plus
d'autonomie aux régions avec
éventuellement même un pouvoir
législatif délayé aux régions sur
l'ensemble des objets d'une aile jospin
était en vie dans son rapport on va
davantage enfin valoriser le statut du
parlementaire en échange mais il manque
une et lui mais alors dans ce club est
une idée c'est par ailleurs une autre
chose qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il faut
réduire le nombre de députés parce que
honnêtement 577 députés sans cumul il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas des responsabilités
pour tout le monde et nous faudrait le
faire il ya trop de parlementaires mais
quoi qu'il arrive je me permets de vous
signaler que donner des responsabilités
un jeu et un rôle à 900 parlementaires
sans cumul et vous allez avoir beaucoup
de gens qui vont s'ennuyer
c'est vrai très rapidement un mot du
d'un autre d'une autre et cotisations du
rapport l'hémicycle sur le banc son
pouvoir prendre la parole sans
s'exprimer franchement ça va ça va faire
des frustrés 1
le changement des règles de parrainage
150000 parrainage citoyen où il des 500
parrainages d'élus ça j'ai souffert il
faut changer le système il faut le
changer parce qu'à chaque fois on voit
bien que tout ça devient très compliqué
même pour des candidats alors moins on
peut dire mot rice et 1% et c'est bon
mais pour ceux qui comme marine le pen
étaient crédités de scores élevés
le combat
le risque de ne pas se retrouver au
premier tour de la présidentielle n'est
pas supportable alors passer au mercredi
encore un texte rejeté au sénat
c'est un symbole fort c'est le premier
budget du quinquennat
hollande il a été rejeté par le sénat
les socialistes ont tenté en vain de
convaincre les communistes mais rien n'y
a fait les sénateurs centristes ont
également voté compte les explications
de paul bouffard venir remettre les
communistes s'abstiennent et le premier
budget du quinquennat hollande est
rejetée au sénat
le volet recettes et retoqué 156 voix
pour et 165 contre à la sortie le
ministre du budget est une fois de plus
confronté à la réalité une
haute-assemblée frondeuse
il ya une majorité de gauche au sénat
mais il n'y a pas une majorité
gouvernementale
comme il y en a une à l'assemblée
nationale mais chacun sait que
l'assemblée nationale a le dernier mot
en cas de contestation avec le sénat et
l'essentiel est bien là
le plf 2013 prévoyait 24 milliards de
hausse d'impôts
au moment du vote les sénateurs
communistes ne soutiennent pas le
gouvernement
nous pensons comme l'a rappelé thierry
foucaud tout à l'heure qu'il ne faut pas
s'arrêter au milieu du gué
c'est avec un esprit véritablement
responsable que nous prenons cette
décision d' abstention car nous
souhaitons que le budget donne les
moyens à l'état de mener une politique
de progrès social et de progrès humain
après ceux de l'énergie de la
programmation budgétaire et du budget de
la sécurité sociale
c'est le quatrième texte repoussé par la
haute assemblée pourtant de gauche le
texte reviendra à l'assemblée nationale
avec une adoption définitive avant le 20
décembre
oui alors le fait d'aller jeter
également leur deuxième lecture le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2013 alors fermera
encore un texte rejeté les sénateurs
centristes disent c'est un grand gâchis
c'est presque la fin du bicamérisme on
va pas au bout des textes et du coup
c'est rejeter le même mot
après quelques amendements après
quelques lectures heureusement que ces
textes sont rejetés sont des mauvais
texte
oui bon pour aller au bout de ses
lectures c'est ce que dit jean arthuis
que vous connaissez bien qu'atteint
sénateurs centristes bien sûr mais bon
écoutez c'est le jeu
classique on l'a vu des dizaines de fois
dans l'histoire du sénat de textes qui
après sont rejetés au moment des motions
de procédure vous poussez pas de
raffinement que ces textes soient
rejetées sans qu'on aille au bout de
l'examen n'est pas la fin du bicamérisme
comme il le dit nous ont écoutés j'aime
beaucoup jean arthuis mais je n'avais
pas vu ça comme ça mais ça semblait
cette semaine au contraire il ya eu
aucune opposition dans l'hémicycle sur
quoi que ce soit notamment le projet de
loi sur le logement qui avait été
âprement débattus avant d'être rejetée
par le conseil constitutionnel a été la
adoptée très facilement vous avez senti
cette vacance sur les bancs de l'ump
cette semaine oui c'est vrai d'ailleurs
le contraire
ces moments dans la vie où tout d'un
coup les esprits sont concentrés sur
d'autres sujets et si on revient un
petit peu sur le fond de ce projet de
loi de finances ya rien qui trouve grâce
à vos yeux le projet de loi de finances
est une folie totale
titou c'est aussi simple que ça on a
asséché le financement de l'économie
française
cher e
mélenchon avait dit de françois hollande
que c'était un capitaine de pédalos
excusez moi je trouve c'est un amiral
d'optimiste ces petits bateaux parce
qu'il tire des bords pendant meilleur
batscap cetc du zig zag permanent
franchement on vient de voter en étant
débat sur la banque publique
d'investissement mais la loi de finances
a grosso modo tout fait pour empêcher
les pme les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire trouver les financements
on a mis des niveaux de prélèvements
obligatoires tels que le business angel
le private equity les sociétés de
capital risque
l'autofinancement des entreprises dont
on sait qu'il est largement inférieur à
l'allemagne tout ça contribuera à une
chose c'est que les socialistes ne sont
pas responsables de la crise je suis
d'accord avec eux mais ils seront
responsables de la récession la
récession de 2013 ça sera la leur
malheureusement pour les français mais
ils remettent ça sur l'héritage de
nicolas sarkozy - little au montage je
dis que quand on créé toutes les
conditions pour mettre l'économie
française a mal on peut pas uniquement
se porter sur l'héritage et j'observe
pareil
heures que dans un certain nombre de
pays on commence à avoir les prémices
d'un léger redressement d'économies
s'est pas encore bien entendu
merveilleux mais on le voit dans
quelques pays
et j'observe par ailleurs que le
président de la db c'est eux monsieur
draghi annonce une reprise en europe à
partir du deuxième semestre 2013 pour
nous on sait pas quand et moi je vous
dis quand vous adresser des signaux
politiques comme ceux qui ont été
adressés à tous ceux qui créent de la
richesse dans le pays où on a stigmatisé
les chefs d'entreprise les artisans les
commerçants les professions libérales
quand on leur à idées des avalanches de
prélèvements obligatoires
supplémentaires et quand on a tenu le
discours qui a été le leur
vous décourager toute bonne volonté
c'est ce qu'on appelle les anticipations
en économie et ils les ont fait jouer à
fond mais à fond sur le frein chose qui
doit faire plaisir c'est que cette
semaine le gouvernement a décidé de
donner un coup d'accélérateur aux
mesures préconisées par louis gallois
l'idée notamment du crédit d'impôt pour
les entreprises va faire partie du
collectif budgétaire examiné en
commission ça n'était pas prévu
explication d'elisa bertolo oui il
arrive plus tôt que prévu à l'assemblée
la commission des finances examine ce
soir l'amendement gouvernemental sur la
création du crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité
d'ici fin 2014 il permettra aux
entreprises de dégager 20 milliards
d'euros une réduction d'impôt de 4 % en
2013 6% en 2014
une mesure jugée plus que nécessaire par
jean marc ayrault
le gouvernement a décidé d'aller plus
vite encore et de proposer au parlement
dans la loi de finances rectificative
le crédit d'impôt pour qu'il soit
effectif pour les entreprises dès le 1er
janvier 2013
et c'est là que j'appelle l'assemblée
nationales à se mobiliser et à créer un
message de confiance pour
l'investissement et l'emploi dans notre
pays une déclaration destinée à
mobiliser les députés de la majorité les
socialistes ont fait connaître leur
mécontentement au gouvernement
il demande plus de contrepartie aux
entreprises des sous-amendements ont
d'ores et déjà
déposé en commission nous avons joué
notre rôle qui est de faire en sorte que
le parlement précise l'utilisation qui
doit être fait du crédit d'impôt et
laisse à la négociation sociale comme
c'est souhaité le rôle de contrôle et de
vérifier de faire en sorte que ce crédit
d'impôt soit utilisé pour des gains de
compétitivité pour les investissements
pour la recherche pour l'innovation
le gouvernement se dit prêt à améliorer
le dispositif en tenant compte des idées
des députés socialistes
le texte sera discuté dans l'hémicycle
dès lundi 3 décembre
alors ce crédit d'impôt qui arrive plus
tôt que prévu dans l'hémicycle une bonne
nouvelle vous voterez cet amendement il
faut le voir précisément comment il
sortira des travaux de la commission
avant de se prononcer mais globalement
oui enfin il ya des amendements après
qui peuvent être adoptés des dernières
négociations et c'est ce que je dis
c'est qu'il faut autre chose que
simplement une mesure par ci par là ça
peut pas être simplement une espèce de
saupoudrage il faudrait un vrai plan
fiscal
un plan fiscal qui tire les conséquences
le pacte de compétitivité de miyama
s'affaissait ça fait sept mois de
chômage
ça fait sept mois qui nous annonce des
mesures mais mais moi j'attends un plan
dans lequel grosso modo on met quatre
éléments sur la table
le premier comme on améliore le fonds de
roulement l'autofinancement des
entreprises françaises qui grosso modo
deux fois inférieur à l'autofinancement
allemand deuxièmement comment on est en
place les conditions du financement de
l'économie française parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a un lien direct entre votre
capitalisation le jour de votre création
vos fonds propres au moment de votre
création et votre développement à dix
ans or les francs les entreprises
françaises sont sous dotées et non plus
souvent accès aux banques
troisième sujet comment mettons en place
des vraies mesures de flexibilisation
mais la banque publique d'investissement
c'est simplement le regroupement
d'institutions qui existe déjà
troisième élément comment mettons en
place une vraie flexibilité du marché du
travail en france parce que
et attendez j'ai roulé sondés annonçant
qu'elle façon nouvelle et quatrième
élément quatrième élément comment
mettons en place une vraie réduction de
la dépense publique pour conditionner la
réduction des prélèvements obligatoires
en france pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat et des capacités
d'investissement à l'économie française
sur le coût du travail il ya des
négociations en ce moment qui pourrait
éventuellement trouver un accord
historique pas non plus vous de ça ne
trouvait pas grâce à vos yeux des
questions le vrai sujet il faut le dire
comme ça parce que c'est ainsi que ça se
pose chez un artisan
j'ai un commerce personne n'a le temps
d'essai le licenciement ce sujet était
pour un contrat de travail unique à
droits progressifs bon parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que on a tellement
rigidifier le droit du travail en france
qu'on l'a précarisés en fait tous les
français ou presque aujourd'hui sont
embauchés en cdd ou par intérim et
aujourd'hui on a des dérives qui sont
totalement scandaleuse comme le
développement des stages pour faire
appel à des surcroîts d'activité aller
chez darty ou aller chez virgin on vous
embauchent des stagiaires par paquets de
dix écoutez moi bien par paquets de dix
au moment de noël parce que plutôt que
de payer un salarié
on va prendre un stagiaire bon ben ça
c'est des comportements inacceptables et
en même temps on a besoin de donner de
la flexibilité à un patron de pme pour
qu'il ne soit pas dans l' angoisse
s'il lui arrive malheureusement s'il est
obligé de licencier
voilà on va voir mais il faut donner de
la souplesse pour licencier lorsque
l'activité baisse parce que sinon le
patron et n'embauchent pas et ça c'est
un frein à l'emploi alors bâtir le
dernier sujet au sujet le dernier sujet
c'est qu'il nous faut absolument
redonner remettre le pays au travail
en bossant un peu plus doux ma
proposition qui pour moi reste toujours
d'actualité de 37 heures de travail par
semaine passée un autre sujet nous
sommes jeudi et comme tous les jeudis eh
bien on parle du mariage pour tous à
l'assemblée nationale
la commission des lois auditionne tous
les jeudis en vue de l'examen du projet
de loi ouvrant le mariage et l'adoption
aux personnes du même sexe cette fois
c'est au tour des instances religieuses
c'est un sujet de thibault le floch
andré vingt-trois occupe toi de ton
culte c'est avec ce slogan qu'une
trentaine de personnes pro mariage homo
ont décidé de manifester contre
l'audition par les députés des
représentants des cultes
ces derniers quant à eux estime qu'il
est normal de les auditionner n'y a pas
de raison que les représentants des
cultes n'ai pas droit au chapitre
tout simplement mais on veut pas faire
la loi ni moi j'irais pas manifester
contre le gouvernement
mais j'aime bien dire pourquoi je suis
pas d'accord avec ce qu'ils proposent
salle lamartine l'ambiance n'est pas à
la manifestation mais à la réflexion
l'ensemble des représentants des cultes
à l'exception des bouddhistes ont
réaffirmé leur hostilité à l'ouverture
du mariage pour les couples homosexuels
une position que regrettent les députés
de gauche qui siègent dans cette
commission
et vous le savez mieux que quiconque
vous qui représentez la religion juive
vous savez mieux que quiconque vous qui
représentez la religion musulmane
représentez la religion protestante
ça a toujours été les autres qui vous
ont exclu et cette espèce d'exclusion
n'est-il pas enfin temps d'y mettre fin
pour l'une des parties essentielles de
notre société
chacun campe sur ses positions ce qui
donne l'impression à certains religieux
que le débat est biaisé la difficulté
qui s'est posé à nous cet après midi
c'est d'être représentés tous ensemble
comme les religions il n'y avait pas de
députés ump ou de députés de droite qui
ont peu cacan poser des questions ce qui
a généré une image tout à fait
surprenante de religions monothéistes
face à des députés socialistes
l'audition est également jugée trop
courte mais difficile d'accorder les
points de vue en deux heures alors que
l'homosexualité reste un sujet sulfureux
pour les principales religions
monothéistes alors que dit le député
maire hervé morin sur le mariage porthos
on aurait eu un contrat d'union civile
on aurait évité cette cette guerre dans
le pays dont on n'a pas besoin quand
j'avais 7 ans ont lieu sont contre
évidemment non mais pour le pour
beaucoup le mariage a un côté sacré est
donc plutôt que d'employer mon mariage
c'est le mot qui vous c'est
l'appellation oui c'est un mariage
la filiation aucun problème pour signer
un contrat d'union quoi d'être de
d'officier pour un contrat d'union
civile à la mairie de d'un couple
homosexuel sera un contrat d'union
civile de toute façon pas de mariage
religieux la politique la politique ce
sont aussi des mots parce que ces mots
ce sont des symboles donc à l'oeuvre
pour certains à droite on pense
notamment à françois fillon et d'eau le
problème c'était la filiation l'adoption
des sans voix je suis pour l'adoption
par les couples homosexuels pour une
raison simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un régime de faux cul quand
vous êtes homosexuel qu'est ce que vous
faites ou cachés dans le placard votre
compagnon vous faites à gré parce que
les célibataires ont droit d'adopter en
france et puis cet enfant fini par
arriver dans la maison et il est élevé
par un couple et donc de deux choses
l'une soit la loi française considère
que en effet il faut un père et une mère
et dans ce cas là on interdit l'adoption
par un couple parent célibataire
soit on en tire les conséquences et les
conséquences et qu'aujourd'hui on a un
enfant qui est adoptée par un parent qui
est élevé par deux parents et où l'autre
n'a aucun moyen d'assurer sa protection
du transmettre son patrimoine etc etc
donc je dis au nom du droit de l'enfant
au nom de la protection de l'enfant qui
va être élevé par deux mers ou de père -
même sans perturber je peux pas vous
dire contraire je ne pense qu'à un
enfant et mieux avec un père et une mère
tu es la plus de chances de s'en sortir
bon si tout n'est pas parfait dans notre
monde dans le monde des hétérosexuels
loin s'en faut mais mais honnêtement je
suis favorable parce que je veux
protéger l'enfant qui aujourd'hui existe
il ya à peu près une quarantaine
d'enfants chaque année ils sont adoptés
par un célibataire et qui sont élevées
ensuite par un couple homosexuel
donc tous les to les n'est pas parfait
dans le monde des hétérosexuels ce sera
la phrase merci et nous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine